[Music]
the devil has come to tell but don't
worry all he wants to do is stage a
magic show this absurd premise forms a
central plot of Mikhail Bulgakov's
masterpiece The Master and Margarita
written in Moscow during the 1930s this
surreal blend of political satire
historical fiction and occult mysticism
has earned a legacy as one of the 20th
century's greatest novels and one of its
strangers the story begins when a
meeting between two members of Moscow's
literary elite is interrupted by a
strange gentleman named wole and who
presents himself as a foreign scholar
invited to give a presentation on black
magic as a stranger engages the two
companions in a philosophical debate and
makes ominous predictions about their
fates the reader is suddenly transported
to first century Jerusalem there a
tormented Pontius pilot reluctantly
sentences Jesus of Nazareth to death
with the narrative shifting between the
two settings Roland and his entourage as
izella curuvija Geller and a giant cat
named behemoth I seem to have uncanny
magical powers which they used to stage
their performance while leaving a trail
of havoc and confusion in their wake
much of the novel's dark humor comes not
only from this demonic mischief but also
the backdrop against which it occurs
will Garko story takes place in the same
setting where it was written the USSR at
the height of the Stalinist period their
artists and authors worked under strict
censorship subject to imprisonment exile
or execution if they were seen as
undermining state ideology even when
approved their work along with housing
travel and everything else was governed
by convoluted bureaucracy in the novel
Roland manipulates his system along with
the fabric of reality to hilarious
results as heads are separated from
bodies and money rains from the sky
the citizens of Moscow react with petty
self-interest illustrating how Soviet
society bred greed and cynicism
despite its ideals and the
matter-of-fact narration deliberately
blends a strangeness of the supernatural
events with the everyday absurdity of
Soviet life so how did Bulgakov managed
to publish such a subversive novel under
an oppressive regime well he didn't he
worked on the master and margarita for
over 10 years
but while Stalin's personal favor may
have kept the duck off soap from severe
persecution many of his plays and
writings were kept from production
leaving him safe that effectively
silenced upon the author's death in 1940
the manuscript remained unpublished a
censored version was eventually printed
in the 1960s while copies of the
unabridged manuscript continued to
circulate among underground literary
circles the full text was only published
in 1973 over 30 years after its
completion Boogaard coughs experiences
with censorship and artistic frustration
lend an autobiographical heir to the
second part of the novel when we are
finally introduced to its namesake the
master is a nameless author who's worked
for years on a novel but burned the
manuscript after it was rejected by
publishers just as Bulgakov had done
with his own world yet the true
protagonist is the Masters mistress
margarita her devotion to her lover's
abandoned dream there's a strange
connection to the diabolical company's
escapades and carries the story to it's
surreal climax
despite its dark humor and complex
structure the Master and Margarita is at
its heart a meditation on art love and
redemption that never loses itself in
cynicism and the books long overdue
publication and survival against yachts
is a testament to what Wolin tells the
master
manuscripts don't burn ready to take a
crack at the master and margarita but
can't read Russian it's important that
you get the right translation we've left
links to two of our favorites on edy
ted.com slash books